yes I do know that my rug is dirty but
you clicked on the video of a grown
woman doing the yoga challenge with her
dog so who are we to judge that's right
today I am doing the yoga challenge if
you don't know what the yoga challenge
is it's a bunch of people on YouTube
getting together as partners and trying
to do very difficult yoga poses because
do we need and reasons anymore but the
videos are entertaining because most of
us are really terrible at Yoga
with the exception of a few of you that
are actually really good at it and use
this challenge to show off that's like
someone going to karaoke
I can sing decently a nice thing Adele
and you're like why but today I'm doing
the yoga challenge or someone that I
trust more than anyone else in this kind
of thing and that is my dog goose what a
grand entrance I know I don't think this
is gonna be a great idea
either but before we get started we have
to change and you are yoga clothes
that's right I can't do yoga like this
let's change into our yoga clothes much
better okay let's get started I know
this is not gonna go well I agree great
we'll start real easy okay
it's just your stretching or your butt
up
yeah I do think we're doing it though
okay gonna hold it that's what yoga is
but you're but wait are we doing it
we're doing it goes we are the best at
this this is a new pose
it's called exploiting your animal okay
what's the next one you lay down good
we're doing it goes it's happening look
we're doing it we are nailing this
high-five later
each Suellen on Caspar Lee just kidding
you guys are adorable oh this one's easy
classic jump art every yoga class has it
see they're jumping and then they're
making a heart got it one two three jump
and make a heart with their bodies
because it's yoga one two three
did you do it did you do it one two
three you know did you do it I'm gonna
trust you if you say you did it then I
trust you I don't think you're getting
that bone out of anxiety because you
just like to mean I think that you
probably did your side of the heart so
now that next oh this one's easy okay
you just stay there I just tilt this
dumb so they can really see it we're
doing yet yeah
sharing the same emotion okay what's the
next one oh this one's easy
we're doing it yeah yoga last one pretty
a good one oh okay you just lay down
okay sometimes you gotta get yeah you
just got a leg - in your back that's not
yoga my girls always the way to the end
to do that you're aligning your chakras
right now but rubbing your butt on my
couch are we doing - we're doing it
close we're doing yoga
what are you go that was good
I feel the challenge I think that we
really nailed it and so it's pretty
pointless for anyone else to even
attempt to do this kind of challenge so
good luck [ __ ] I don't know okay
great we'll start real easy okay but
it's just you're stretching